I came from a Christian background but
it wasn't anything of any in depth you
know we sort of go to church
superficially if there was a holiday we
would go and you know celebrate maybe
say grace before a meal but it wasn't
anything like most Christians you know
it wasn't really serious you know if you
will not to disrespect anyone but that's
just the nature of how we grew up so but
when they went up to pray they you know
they excuse themselves we were in the
back of the Masjid and they went to the
front to offer the prayer and I remember
seeing you know how the Muslims you know
we stand up to pray and everyone stood
up in unison and then it was a silent
prayer so I really had a chance to just
take it in what I was witnessing and
that touched my heart
like like no other then I knew for sure
that this religion beyond what people
were saying about the unity of mankind
you know it's one thing to say there's
one God and that he created everything
that exists he created all human beings
and that all human beings are equal in
the sight of God and if you're going to
make any distinguishing things amongst
human beings it should be based on their
character it's one thing to say that but
then when you see everyone standing up
together bowing standing up and putting
your forehead on the ground in unison
that had an effect on me that at that
moment I knew this what this life was
for me so you ended up in the Masjid and
the brothers from Philly were talking
about the pure monotheism yes but
there's only one God God's not a Trinity
God's not in a human form they went over
that that connected with your heart they
were talking about the previous books
that were that were given to many people
I'm just bringing him up to speed
probably some of the conversation what
it went like we believe as Muslims at
Moses he was given the Torah and it's
original yes we don't have it today and
it's original Jesus peace be upon him
the injeel it was given a locks about
this in the verbatim word of god the
quran what he was given the original
what abraham was given the original
right we don't have any of those
original books everything's been changed
everything so they probably now they're
talking about the Quran yeah tamper free
tamper proof we have it and that's
connecting with your heart yes
and then you see the now you see the
unification yes not of just of God being
one but now the Muslims talk about that
right there was no status first of all I
should go circle back a little bit when
I first walked into the Masjid there
were no chairs mhm it was all you know
carpet and that right humbles you do
ever I was just about to say that you
have a humbling God yes because you're
sitting on the floor now
yeah again these are all almost like
subliminal things that just you know
when you're angry for instance you know
we're taught our Prophet SAW sallam said
if you're angry and you're in a standing
position sit down that that bought that
change in body posture just humbles you
and relaxes you so in the absence of
even being angry you go into a Masjid
you just sit down you're humbling
ourselves before God before you even
engage in any type of worship in terms
of pray or reading the Quran etc so yes
so that that experience of just being in
the Masjid and sitting down was very you
know very relaxing and warm and it was
unique to me but to see there was no
status we're all equal here standing
alone there was no specific prayers my
parking space for them for the Imam or
something like that we're all the same
here you could be praying next to a
millionaire or you could be saying to
someone who has limited means doesn't
matter when you're on this prayer line
and beyond we're all humbling ourselves
before God Almighty didn't amalgam X in
his letter when he went because first he
was with this nation yes that really
doesn't have anything to do with the
true Islam right and then he got exposed
to real Islam went to Hajj fifth pillar
of Islam yes and Islam simply means you
guys know already if you watch indeed
show submission to the will of who to
the Creator not yourself money or
anything in creation but the one who
created you now